on attaque prix madame madame benbassa
je vous en prie merci monsieur le
président après de très nombreuses
heures passées sur ses bancs à étudier
la grande majorité des dispositions de
ce texte nous arrivons finalement à
l'amendement qui a causé le plus de
controverses dans l'opinion publique et
a mis le gouvernement dans l'embarras et
aj styles bien sûr comment peut-on
imaginer que la france pays des droits
de l'homme
pis renier le plus cher de ses acquis à
savoir la liberté d'expression comment
peut-on concevoir que la presse
française se retrouve mise les par un
état qui ne se regardaient sanctionner
les mauvais comportements de ses propres
agents lorsqu'il ya lieu la population
qui doit ce texte a su mur soumises à
une surveillance généralisée
cela pour sa part interdit de procéder à
des captation d'image susceptibles
d'identifier des agents de police et de
gendarmerie pour l'automne pour dénoncer
des actes de violences policières
ils arrivent déjà en pratique que les
forces de l'ordre s'oppose à ce qu'elle
soit filmé ou photographié en pleine
action pourtant une circulaire du
ministre de l'intérieur en date du 23
décembre 2008 précise que cette
opposition est contraire au droit
ce problème ainsi que l'impunité qui
règne parfois dans les rangs des forces
de l'ordre et sape la relation de
confiance qui devrait exister entre les
citoyens et les forces de l'ordre
auraient dû être abordées dans ce texte
surtout que les infractions contre
l'intégrité physique ou psychique des
agents sont déjà prévues par le code
pénal
il aurait été en revanche utile de
définir précisément cette notion ainsi
que celle d'un pacte si chic qui savent
elle est aussi flou dans le droit actuel
que dans la présente proposition de loi
mais nous l'avons déjà répété ce texte
est très lacunaire je vous remercie
merci madame la présidente à celle ci
si monsieur le président d'emblée je
voudrais indiquer à la majorité
sénatoriale de que la réécriture de
l'article 24 mai selon nous pas une
bonne idée
l'alternative du texte voté à
l'assemblée nationale était clair
l'abrogation
la proposition de loin du groupe on
march attaquer directement à l'origine
aux journalistes en effet c'est la loi
de 1881 qui était visé c'est le fait de
diffuser des images pouvant porter
atteinte à l'intégrité physique et
psychique d'un agent de police nationale
ou de la gendarmerie nationale ou de la
police municipale qui pouvait pas être
sanctionné d'un an de prison et de 45000
euros damende le tollé fut général et
des centaines de milliers de personnes
sont descendues dans la rue pour
défendre la liberté de la presse et les
libertés publiques
la majorité sénatoriale a habilement
reculer pour mieux sauter vous n'êtes
plus référence à la loi de 1881 monsieur
le rapporteur
vous introduisez dans le code pénal une
disposition générale qui pourra âge 1,6
sur ce point a concerné les journalistes
comme les autres citoyens
le premier alinéa de l'article 226-1 4-1
du code pénal et si limpide qu'il
pourrait passer inaperçu la provocation
dans le but manifeste question a porté
atteinte à son intégrité physique ou
psychique à l'identification d'un agent
de la police nationale d'un militaire de
la gendarmerie nationale ou d'un agent
de la police municipale est puni de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende endroits les mots comptent
vous ne pouvez pas dire que les
journalistes ne peuvent pas être visés
par une telle mesure si la justice le
décide si la justice qui décidera si la
diffusion d'image relève de la
provocation à l'identification ou pas
pouvez-vous mme affirmé que le juge s'il
est saisi de la diffusion d'une image
comprenant le numéro d'immatriculation
par exemple ne décidera pas qu'il y a eu
provocation à l'identification votre
régate rédaction donc laisse entière la
menace contre la liberté de la presse et
renforce fortement les sanctions entre
les diffusion d'image votre parallèle
dans votre rapport avec la provocation
au sujet au suicide à provocations des
mines
à consommer des stupéfiants ou même à
l'assassinât par est éculée outrancier
et surtout erronées sur le plan
juridique enfin n'oublions pas que
l'arctic 24 se doublera de l'article 18
de la loi sur les principes de la
république qui lui aussi autorise des
poursuites d'ordre général pas seulement
en matière de terrorisme contre la
diffusion des images de policiers
gendarmes ou policiers municipaux parmi
d'autres donc nous voterons contre ce
cet article 24 et monsieur le président
pour vous êtes pour vous être agréable
considéré que cela maintenant 90
rectifié déposée par notre groupe est
ici défendu n'oublierai pas merci madame
la présidente
la parole est à janvier alors merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre collègues la rédaction de
l'article 24 tel qu'il est nous est
proposée permet la diffusion sur toutes
les chaînes de télévision sans flouter
le visage des membres des forces de
l'ordre dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions pour eux et leur famille dans
leur quartier leur immeuble à l'école
leurs enfants dans leurs vies civiles et
sociales
ils seront reconnus et le lait les
dangers seront présents à tous les
instants cet article propose des mesures
sans effet dès lors que les millions de
téléspectateurs pourront découvrir le
visage et policiers dans leurs missions
de maintien de l'ordre
trop souvent face à des émeutiers de
plus en plus violents dont les visages
n'apparaissent pas à l'écran
le visage est reconnue comme un élément
d'identification la captation par
l'image d'un visage est encadrée par la
loi
l'article 24 ne définit pas ce qui est
un élément d'identification dès lors
qu'ils excluent le mot visage il crée
une inégalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens pour lesquels on ne peut pas
diffuser leurs visages sans leur accord
et les forces de l'ordre pour lesquels
la diffision la diffusion est admise par
l'article 24 flouter le visage des
forces de l'ordre n'est pas une atteinte
chers collègues à démocratie c'est
préserver les fonctionnaires au service
de la république
les journalistes et je le dis avec force
pourront toujours filmé sans limites les
événements et leurs reportages seront
naturellement à la disposition de la
justice
ce qui sera foutait
c'est la diffusion le floutage des
réserves et donc qu'à la diffusion
quand le fonctionnaire est identifiable
cette mesure a pour seul but
je dis bien pour seul but de protéger
les forces de l'ordre et leur famille
merci la parole est au président
caennais remercie monsieur le président
monsieur ministre monsieur le rapporteur
nous y sommes donc là cet article 24 qui
a tant défrayé la chronique
chers collègues qu'il s'agisse de
l'écriture initial qu'il s'agisse de sa
réécriture pour le moins controversé par
le gouvernement qu'il s'agisse de la
nouvelle écriture faite par la majorité
sénatoriale
aucune ne modifie notre opinion je vous
le dis d'ores et déjà le débat ne pose
pas ce qui voudrait protéger les
policiers ceux qui ne voudraient pas mes
chers collègues oui nos forces de
l'ordre doivent être protégés quand
elles sont attaquées ou menacer leur
famille encore plus permettez moi
l'expression partage cette préoccupation
nous n'avons aucune mansuétude envers
ceux qui incitent à la haine contre les
agents qui font l'honneur de la
république mais je relève qu'ils sont
déjà protégés légalement dans la loi de
1881 et dans le code pénal les policiers
disposent d'un arsenal législatif pour
lutter contre les menaces le harcèlement
les atteintes à la vie privée et serra
et c'est heureux aucun élément sérieux
le démontrent que ces qualifications
juridiques seraient insuffisantes
la protection des policiers passent
d'abord par l'application sans faillir
de ces lois il passe aussi par le
renforcement du lien de confiance entre
la police et la population et c'est là
que le bât blesse
en réalité ce texte traduit la faiblesse
d'un gouvernement qui ne parvient pas à
contenir un phénomène alarmant celui de
la multiplication des violences
policières
le problème c'est de ne pas voir les
raisons profondes de ce malaise
en s'attaquant entre guillemets au
simple image ce n'est pas en cassant le
thermomètre
selon la formule consacrée que baisse la
température la baisse de la
professionnalisation ainsi que la
réduction drastique des effectifs
spécialisée a conduit à une augmentation
massive de la violence c'est cette
orientation qui doit être modifié 2500
blessés chez les jets les jaunes 1800
chez les policiers
122 journalistes blessés ou en train
dans l'exercice de leurs fonctions ce
sont des chiffres qui ne plaisent à
personne et encore moins peut-être ici
dans la haute assemblée
ce que nous disons c'est que la police
française se replie sur elle même sur
ses techniques ses doctrines
or dans une démocratie le niveau de
monopole de la violence légitime est
établie par l'état à partir du moment où
l'état revendique ce monopole
il se doit d'être exemplaire en
démocratie la liberté c'est aussi le
contrôle citoyen sur celles et ceux qui
exercent l'autorité
je n'invente rien c'est l'article 15 de
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen chez le président pour toutes
ces raisons nous ne voterons pas et même
nous demandons la suppression de
l'article 24
merci je sais le questeur suaire
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la liberté de la presse est un bien
tellement précieux que nous devons y
veiller comme à la prunelle de nos yeux
à cet égard monsieur le ministre j'ai lu
avec intérêt il y à quelques temps que
vous aviez déclaré être horrifié par des
images que vous aviez vu d'une
manifestation à paris et ce qui s'était
passé pour que vous ayez pu voir ces
images
monsieur le ministre il a fallu que
quelqu'un les prennent qu'il y ait des
photographes des journalistes qui
rendent compte de ce qui se passe et de
ce qui s'est passé
donc nous sommes pour la liberté de la
presse total intégral il y à une loi de
1881 qui n'a jamais été remise en cause
et qui est un bien extrêmement précieux
non
me semble t'il et je partage bien sûr ce
que vient de dire patrick kenner d'être
fidèle à ce que le sénat est dans ces
moments les plus illustres défenseurs
des libertés de toutes les libertés
on nous dira il faut protéger les forces
de l'ordre
et oui il faut le faire bien sûr mais la
protection qui est censé être proposée
ici ne marche pas l'intention de
provocation mais si une photo par et
kidira ou ne dira pas qu'il y à une
attention provocation ou pas alors
s'agissant de la nécessité absolue de
protéger les forces de l'ordre
je rappelle qu existe et je vais être
très clair dans le code pénal l'article
226-1 l'article 222-3 3-2
l'article 222-3 2-2-2 l'article 222-12 7
l'article 222-7 l'article 226-1 huit
mois de 1978 sur la cnil et vous voyez
monsieur le président j'achève car je ne
voudrais pas où mettre les sorties 24 et
39 de la loi de 1881
donc tout cela existe que sur une ou rsa
supprimer cet article 24 et pour
défendre la parole d'un monsieur marc
laménie merci veut se tester
la parole est à marc laménie merci merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je reconnais de la prise de
parole concernant l'article 24 articles
qui suscite j'irai des des inquiétudes
certes légitime mais dans lequel le choc
il est important aussi de
soutenir l'ensemble des forces de
sécurité je crois que c'est aussi
l'objectif cet article 24 diffusion du
visage ou de tout élément permettant
l'identification d'un fonctionnaire de
police d'un militaire de la gendarmerie
ou d'un policier municipal en soulignant
bien entendu le le le travail de la
commission qui fait aussi référence à la
liberté de la presse relative à la
liberté de la presse loi du de 1881
comme cela a été rappelé répression des
menaces et protection de la vie privée
d'où la faculté aussi de notre
institution de modifier cet article
c'est aussi un travail important qui a
été fait par le rapporteur et l'ensemble
des membres de la commission des lois
protection des forces de sécurité des
forces de l'ordre protéger les membres
de leur famille je crois que c était
aussi souligné contre l'identification
malveillante par cohésion avec l'article
18 on l'a évoqué sommes en fin de
matinée l'article 18 du projet de lois
confortant le respect des principes de
la république et donc dans lequel aussi
certains collègues qui avaient déposé
des amendements pour ajouter aussi des
des catégories aussi de personnes qui
qui sont aussi largement
souvent en en difficulté et injuriée ou
des menaces graves donc et sans oublier
aussi con seconde partie 2 de cet
article 24 référence à la cnil et au
code pénal et garantir la répression de
la constitution de fichier visant des
fonctionnaires et personnes chargées
d'un service public dans un but
malveillant voilà donc je soutiendrai
bien entendu cet article merci la parole
à monsieur thomas dessus merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues hier le sénateur ben
asher pour défendre la vidéo
surveillance généralisée nous demandait
qui a peur aujourd'hui des caméras de
surveillance il répondait les
délinquants
reprenant cette question qui aujourd'hui
chez les fonctionnaires de police dans
l'exercice de leurs fonctions a peur
d'être filmé je n'ai pas la réponse mais
je vous la laisse
monsieur le ministre vous avez affirmé
mardi que les policiers sont les
fonctionnaires les plus contrôlées
poursuivis et sanctionnés mais c'est
bien légitime
heureusement leurs responsabilités sont
immenses ils ont la possibilité de
contrôler d'interpeller d'arrêter
d'utiliser la coercition au nom de
l'état et ceci doit être fait dans le
respect absolu de la proportionnalité
il est donc parfaitement légitime que
l'usager ce pouvoir fasse l'objet d'une
attention constante dans un esprit de
garantie de nos libertés c'est pourquoi
ces fonctionnaires dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions doivent pouvoir être
filmé donner les moyens aux forces de
l'ordre d'empêcher d'être filmés comme
cet article va le permettre va jeter la
suspicion permanente sur leur action
pourtant la confiance doit être rétablie
oui les images que nous pouvons voir ces
derniers mois concernant le maintien de
l'ordre ont permis de faire connaître
des abus on ne protégera pas
l'institution policière avec des
oeillères
il faut lutter contre la mise en danger
de la vie d agent il est temps d'apaiser
de restaurer la confiance et cela passe
par une autre doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre qui est aujourd'hui dans
l'impasse
il est temps d'envisager la désescalade
plutôt que la fuite en avant comme cette
loi accélère
mes chers collègues écoutons nos
concitoyens et les journalistes
laissons-les témoigné permettons lors de
rétablir la confiance trop longtemps
dégradé c'est pour cela que nous
souhaitons l'abrogation de cet article
merci merci la parole est à monsieur
thierry cozic merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la
publicité et la sauvegarde du peuple
tout ce qui est intérêts d'un terrain
public doit être rendu public
en ce sens si la médaille des
colporteurs des papiers public créé en
elle contient l'oeil du peuple ce n'est
sûrement pas un hasard
la problématique que pose cet article 24
c l'anonymisation des agents publics
disposant du monopole de la violence
physique légitime comme se plaisait à le
qualifier max weber
le conseil de l'europe qui n'est ni plus
ni moins le garant des libertés
fondamentales en europe nous a exhorté
en décembre à amender cet article
estimant que ce dernier portait atteinte
à la liberté d'expression
c'est à nous qu'il appartient de veiller
à la compatibilité de ce texte avec les
normes relatives aux droits de l'homme
auxquels je le rappelle la france est
partie on ne peut nier que cet article
va au venir renforcer l'impunité
policière
et cette propension des forces de
l'ordre à s'opposer au fait d'être filmé
au cours d'une opération même si cet
article interdit par an soit filmée il
n'en demeure pas moins qu'il va tout
changer sur le terrain et donner un
blanc seing aux forces de l'ordre pour
s'opposer toujours plus violemment à la
prise d'image je vous parlais en
préambule de la médaille des colporteurs
aujourd'hui cet oeil du peuple ce sont
les caméras
ce sont grâce à elle que nous pouvons
rendre compte de manquement d'alerté de
témoigner elle participe à cette
vigilance d'un peuple
ce n'est pas protégé les forces de
l'ordre que de créer des dispositifs de
nature à nourrir le sentiment de leur
impunité l'état de droit monsieur le
ministre ce n'est pas l'état policier
l'état de droit c'est le droit de
surveiller l'état et
derniére attriste madame lienemann oui
mes chers collègues des arguments
peuvent paraître redondant mais la
sphère est importante
la crise notre république procède aussi
d'une distance croissante entre une
partie de la population et nos forces de
police
il faut donc renouer la confiance
réciproque et ce n'est pas en mettant en
place des dispositifs qui sont qui
cachent davantage les réalités en
permettant que les forces de l'ordre au
motif de la provocation d'identifier
puis s'opposer à des prises image qui va
régler ce problème la première chose
c'est qu'on peut s'étonner du fait que
les autorités policières et l'ensemble
de la de l'état ne se soit pas
suffisamment mobilisé pour utiliser
systématiquement le droit existant qui
devrait pouvoir mieux protéger les
policiers quand ils sont réellement
menacées et nous avons tous en tête un
certain nombre de drames qui sait peut
re qui se sont passées mais de la même
façon nous avons besoin que le pays
reprenne confiance dans le fait qu'on ne
lui cache pas des réalités des pratiques
inacceptables des violences répétitives
et de ce point de vue les mobilisations
sociales qui ont eu lieu comme par
exemple et gilet jaune que vous l'on
voit que le nombre de personnes éborgné
mis en difficulté fine de santé à cause
de ces violences policières et qu' il y
a eu beaucoup de condamnation de ces
gilet jaune tandis que très fréquemment
les rapports de l'igas tenté à minimiser
les pratiques des forces de l'ordre qui
d'ailleurs me relève plus de la carence
de leur encadrement que simplement de
dérive personnelle qui existent mais qui
au bout du compte sont tellement
nombreuses qu'il ya quand même un
problème de système et moi je le dis
tout net
renforcer l'idée qu'il y aurait d'un
côté l'état qui so aveuglément entre
guillemets soutient les forces de police
et d'une manière générale considère que
ceux qui manifestent ne sont pas
d'accord ne sont pas du même quand ça
c'est une menace grave à la république
c'est pourquoi cet article 24 ouvrent
des brèches qui limite les libertés
publiques qui ne renforce pas la
confiance de la police et qui ne sont
pas nécessairement plus efficace dans sa
protection
c'est pourquoi je vous invite à voter la
suppression de cet article très bien
aller par dérogation exceptionnelle
madame taille et polluants je vous
remercie beaucoup monsieur le monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues non le 5 décembre 2020
le président emmanuel macron a parlé de
violences policières
il l'a évoqué on s'est dit enfin il y à
une reconnaissance d'une réalité vécue
sur le terrain et documentée c'est vrai
par des vidéos captées dans la rue et on
attend toujours les propositions pour y
remédier et qu'est ce qu'on a en réalité
en face qui nous est proposé eh bien ce
ne sont pas des solutions pour résorber
ce problème qui est nommé quand on sait
qu'il existe mais c'est au contraire
cette proposition qui veut qui va
participer à un visibiliser ces
violences policières
mais ce n'est pas ça qu'il faut faire
justement pour protéger et les
manifestants et les personnes qui se
sont suicidées violences policières
qu'elle soit manifestants tous pas parce
qu'on l'a vue cela peut arriver
n'importe où n'importe quand et il est
aussi protéger les agents des forces de
l'ordre contre ce sentiment ce sentiment
d'impunité ce sentiment que les choses
ne vont plus dans notre république
entre la population et les forces de
l'ordre il faudrait réparer et là qu'est
ce qu'on nous propose c'est de faire
comme si le problème n'existait pas or
tous et toutes nous le savons il existe
d'ailleurs je crois monsieur le ministre
que vous avez reçu un courrier de la
des familles des victimes de violences
policières de leur avocat qu'ils
souhaitaient participer au beauvau la
sécurité parce que je crois qu'elles
doivent être incluses dans le processus
de débat qui doit permettre de résorber
ces problèmes donc arrêtons de nier ces
problèmes
arrêtons d'essayer de leysin visibiliser
au contraire trouvons les solutions et
ce sera ça bien plus que toute autre
chose qui permettra de protéger les
forces de l'ordre contre ce sentiment
d'injustice et pour notre république
on a besoin d'une police qui soit
présente
on a besoin d'une police qui soit qu'ils
soient respectés on a besoin d'une
police avec des liens forts avec la
population mais on a besoin aussi et
c'est notre histoire c'est l'histoire de
notre république d'une presse forte
libre indépendante et qui prenne toute
sa place pour informer les citoyens et
les citoyennes
merci je passe
j'en viens maintenant aux amendements
nous commençons par trois amendements
identiques de suppression madame la
présidente assassi me confirme qu'elle a
défendu le 90 rectifier j'en suis donc
aux 116 madame benbassa et monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dans cette nouvelle rédaction
de l'article 24 la provocation un
l'identification a été substituée à la
diffusion malveillantes d'image des
forces de l'ordre
les peines prévues ont été alourdis et
ce nouveau délit introduit dans le code
pénal et non dans la loi du 29 juillet
1881 sur la liberté de la presse
s'applique également aux familles des
forces de l'ordre cette rédaction est
insatisfaisante
la disposition est définie de manière
trop large et elle ouvre la voie à des
interprétations arbitrales qui pourrait
contribuer à entraver le travail des
journalistes
ces dispositions portent une atteinte
disproportionnée à la liberté
d'expression car le risque de sanctions
l'obligation
de supprimer tout élément
d'identification sur les vidéos ou
images montrant des policiers et le
critère d'intention vous me le
concéderez très larges et floues
sont autant d'éléments de nature à
dissuader la documentation de l'action
de la police en ce sens ces dispositions
clés aussi des obstacles au contrôle de
l'action des policiers et gendarmes par
les vidéos de policiers ont été
essentiels pour dénoncer les pratiques
illégales des forces de l'ordre de
certaines forces de l'ordre une partie
et dans certains cas permettre
l'ouverture d'une enquête
soulignons enfin la vie de la défenseur
des droits qui stipule que la
l'infraction prévue par cette
proposition de loi n'est pas nécessaire
à la protection des policiers et
gendarmes
nous sommes côtes contre cette
disposition et cet amendement demandent
sa suppression je vous la met merci la
maman de 280 à monsieur à
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre chers collègues après le
balayage en commission d'un article 24
unanimement jugés attentatoires aux
libertés et inapplicable les rapporteurs
du texte ont introduit un amendement de
réécriture mais pour nous les principaux
écueils qui se trouvait dans la version
initiale n'ont pas été corrigées d'abord
du fait de l'imprécision de l'arctique
qui le rend juridiquement fragile et
inapplicable les difficultés liées à la
caractérisation de l'intendant
l'intentionnalité n'ont pas été
dissipées le maintien de la mention de
but manifeste qu'il soit porté atteinte
à l'intégrité physique ou psychique de
la victime qu'on continue d'octroyer aux
forces de l'ordre une marge de manoeuvre
conséquente et subjectif sur leur
interprétation de l'intention
malveillante
et si la provocation et pénalement
déterminer la notion d'identification
quant à elle ne constitue pas en
elle-même un fait punissable
il paraît donc juridiquement dangereux
de faire reposer l'élément matériel
de ce nouveau délit sur une non
d'infraction de plus en l'état le texte
ne précise pas si c'est uniquement la
provocation qui est puni à la
provocation et l'identification ayant in
fine et abouti à l'identification des
policiers concernés ou l'ensemble des
provocations sans considération de leurs
résultats au delà
nous pensons aussi qu'il y à redon danse
de l'arte ne l'article par rapport à
d'autres textes deux articles de la loi
de 1881 l'arctique 24 et l'article 39
et puis un certain nombre de
dispositions avec le droit pénal
existant qui punit le harcèlement moral
las le cyber harcèlement les menaces les
violences volontaires les atteintes à la
représentation la divulgation de données
personnelles et enfin il pose problème
avec la conjonction de l'article 18 du
projet de loi respect des principes de
la république et donc pour toutes ces
raisons nous demandons la suppression de
l'article
merci monsieur le rapporteur avis de la
commission sur ces trois amendements
identiques mais ce prêt dans mes chers
collègues sur un amendement de cette
importance vous comprendrez que je vous
fasse une réponse un peu plus longue que
d'habitude en remerciant les orateurs
pour certains d'entre eux j'ai eu
l'impression qu'on me disait la réponse
est non mais au fait quelle était la
question mais au moins madame à ça si je
vous remercie parce que vous avez là
plaidoyer cohérent des raisons pour
lesquelles vous n'êtes pas d'accord pour
adopter cet article et je vais essayer
de vous expliquer pourquoi
de notre point de vue de la commission
des lois il faut l'adopter dans son
article dense été très cohérent ce que
vous avez dit c'est ce que je viens de
vous dire pas tous excusez moi mais j'ai
pas je vais citer personne pour ne vexer
personne
vingt neuf auquel vous avez fait
allusion indirectement puisque moi
parler de la convention des droits de
l'homme et d'un certain nombre de sujets
connexes
il est écrit nul ne doit être inquiété
pour ses opinions même religieuses
pourvu que leur manifestation ne trouble
pas l'ordre public établi par la loi je
réponds à monsieur sueur qui a eu lui
aussi une intervention très cohérente
dont la décision du conseil
constitutionnel de 1985 à ce sujet et
iront les tirerons les conséquences
mais ceux-ci heures de cet article 10 il
est écrit il appartient au législateur
d'opérer la conciliation nécessaire
entre le respect des libertés d'une part
et la sauvegarde de l'ordre public
d'autre part sans lequel exercice des
libertés ne serait être assuré dans une
décision du conseil constitutionnel
ultérieure de mars 2003 il est écrit ce
qui précise la précédente
il appartient au législateur d'assurer
la conciliation entre prévention d
atteindre à l'ordre public recherche des
auteurs d'infraction et l'exercice des
libertés auxquelles figure bien
évidemment la liberté d'expression et la
liberté de la presse tout ça m'amène à
vous dire que quand nous avons décidé de
réécrire cet article et nous avons reçue
de l'assemblée nationale un texte qui de
notre point de vue était imparfait qui
porta talent se l'est dit je le redis
ici à au principe de nécessité de
constitutionnalité se répondent à madame
de la gontrie qu'à raison là dessus et
qui portait atteinte à un article
significatif de la convention des droits
de l'homme
donc nous ne pouvions pas bien
évidemment monsieur kenner vous avez
raison nous sénateurs porter des
traditions qui sont les nôtres accepté
cet article tel qu'il est écrit et créé
un peu dans la précipitation
nous ne pouvions pas accepter
que l'on rajoute en amendement
complémentaires de la part de nos
collègues des députés qui n'était
nécessaire qu'il y une exigence que la
volonté malveillantes soit manifeste
ce qui ne veut rien dire et le fait que
ça s'applique sans préjudice du droit
d'informer ce qui n'a aucune portée
donc nous ne sommes pas d'accord nous
l'avons exprimé à plusieurs reprises
avec l'arctique tel qui sort de
l'assemblée mais nous sommes d'accord
monsieur le ministre
avec l'intention exprimée par les
auteurs du texte et réitérée à plusieurs
reprises dans les auditions que nous
avons faite par le ministre de
l'intérieur
il faut un article spécifique pour
préserver l'identification des forces de
l'ordre en opération nous sommes
d'accord avec cette intention nous
sommes ce que nous sommes
nous nous sommes mis au travail pour
réécrire l'article
isabelle tu prends un petit mais nous
l'avons fait ceci avec pourrait
fréquenter vrai sera longue à ce que le
souci de sortir de cette opposition
délai entre la protection des forces de
sécurité intérieure et la liberté de la
presse
et parce que et là dessus se mettre
d'accord avec plusieurs orateurs
parce que évidemment que tel qui était
écrit le texte précédent
le risque d' auto-censure des
journalistes était évident est que même
si dans le texte
si nous avions décidé de l'améliorer en
repartant du texte de l'assemblée
on aurait abouti toujours à cette
opposition délétère est donc au risque
d' auto-censure jusque là nous sommes je
pense en phase
bon alors nous réécrivons que et je le
dis pour manama s'assied et pour d'autre
qu' il ne sera plus possible de
poursuivre un journaliste ou un
rédacteur ou quelques uns sont carte de
presse qui filme sur le fondement de la
diffusion des images mais que
on a un délit qui poursuit les
provocations avec une attention dolosive
avec l'intention de nuire et qui est
réprimée et nous avons mis madame
benbassa un quantum de peine plus lourd
que précédemment pourquoi parce que
simultanément
l'article 18 de la loi qui protège les
principes de la république a mis un
article avec un quantum de peine plus
lourd complémentaire s qui s'adresse à
tous les citoyens
nous nous adressons forces de l'ordre en
opération et qu'il fallait harmoniser
les quantum de peine
la raison pour laquelle nous avons durci
ses peines pour des raisons évidentes de
cohérence entre deux articles dit c'est
vrai c'est un problème se discute
presque simultanément
alors qu'est ce que nous faisons le
nouvel article
ce je le redis se compose de deux
parties inscrite dans le code pénal
donc plus dans la loi sur la liberté de
la presse
la première partie entend protéger les
forces de l'ordre contre la volonté
malveillante de l'identifier donc je
reprends l'exemple
un journaliste est évidemment le droit
de filmer ce qu'il veut et dans notre
conception de la liberté évidemment
qu'il a le droit de diffuser en fonction
de ça des longs tôt lui su ce qu'il
estime nécessaire de diffuser
s'il met un numéro d'identification pour
dire le policier en question que vous
pouvez identifier de telle manière m'a
sauvé la vie je vais lui offrir des
chocolats
il est pas sous le coup du délit mais si
il est démontré sans que l'action soit
nécessaire au final s'il est démontré
que ce cette identification a été faire
dans l'intention de nuire ainsi des
images mais pas que des images si des
fichiers si des données personnelles
donnés par des journalistes sont
reprises par d'autres avec une intention
malveillante là il ya un délit et nous
protégeons les forces de l'ordre
conformément à l'article 10 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et aux
interprétations successives du conseil
constitutionnel je suis sûr que nous
respectons dans cet article les
principes de nécessité et de
proportionnalité
j'ai voulu vraiment regarder les choses
n'a passé beaucoup de temps je vous
assure on a fait beaucoup d'auditions
j'ai consulté d'éminents juristes qui
parfois sont pas tous d'accord entre eux
au plus haut niveau de l'état
je suis sûr que ce nouvel article
respecte ces deux principes et que c'est
évidemment l'essentiel pour le conseil
constitutionnel puisque à juste titre le
premier ministre a décidé de saisir le
conseil constitutionnel à l'issue de du
vôtre et donc nous avons cette
infraction et ensuite nous avons une
seconde partie qui est quand même mes
chers collègues
la moindre des choses qui vise
conformément à l'avis de la cnil saisie
par le président ont pu fait remis à la
commission des lois à garantir la
répression de la constitution de fichier
visant des fonctionnaires et personnes
chargées d'un service public dans un but
malveillant que ce fichier soit des
images ou pas on ne trouve où vous ne
trouvez pas le mot images dans cet
amendement
j'ai d'ailleurs entendu sur certaines
chaînes des commentaires de certains qui
visiblement n'ont pas lu cet article et
qui disent on sanctionne la diffusion du
match s'cusez moi c'est pas ce qui est
écrit ni dans la lettre ni dans l'espace
donc nous appliquons tout simplement
dans le respect des directives
européennes la la loi informatique et
libertés évidemment avec un quantum de
peine correspondant à la nature des
personnes concernées au total on a
adapté que simple qui ne se substitue
pas là aussi j'ai consulté d'éminents
juristes
à d'autres les articles du code pénal
est évidemment que quand nous avons 10
youn et le procureur général mot la sda
cour de cassation il nous a donné un
mémorandum j'ai dit ce matin très
complet avec les griefs que l'on pouvait
faire la précédente rédaction mais avec
ce qu'il fallait attendre dans la
nouvelle je prétends que nous sommes
nous avons répondu à tous ces griefs et
que la nouvelle rédaction est une
rédaction
juridiquement correct équilibre et
respectueuse de la déclaration des
droits de l'homme raison pour laquelle
je donne un avis défavorable aux
amendements de suppression et je vous
invite à voter cet article merci
monsieur le rapporteur merci pour les
avis suivant de rester à 2 minutes 30
par amendement la commission prend la
parole quand elle le souhaite mais le
temps de parole est quand même limité à
2 30 parvis pas maintenant c'est
sûrement mais c'est même essentiel
monsieur rapporteur
c'est essentiel mais le temps et le
règlement est le même pour tout le monde
monsieur le ministre à vis du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président je je je rentrerai
pas sur les attendus de l'article 24
j'en suis expliqué à la tribune de votre
assemblée lors de la discussion générale
puisque le présente dans le public a
souhaité confier au parlement le soin de
réécrire cela comme l'assemblée statique
24 en gardant ses buts ses buts qui sont
nobles et je veux dire prise d'un kader
que si je peux interrogé sur non ils
auraient pu constater monsieur le
président sur le fait qu' on aurait pu
déposer un amendement gouvernemental
ainsi bien sûr soumis à l'avis des
parlementaires mais qui aurait créé
ainsi législation
je l'entend bien tout d'abord répondre
au président le canard que c'est une
réplique j'entends souvent de dire mais
ça existe déjà plusieurs années je me
suis posé évidemment cette question je
ne sais pas c'était un tri-nations
pénale permettent de condamner ce que je
constate c'est que sur les faits que
j'ai eu à connaître comme il a un
tailleur quand je dis que j'ai eu à
connaître que les prédécesseurs m'ont
laissé et compris vert du gouvernement
précédent dont vous faisiez partie
il n'y a jamais eu de condamnations pour
des divulgation d'identité de policiers
ou de gendarmes dans leur vie
personnelle dans la vie privée même des
collections de photos avec leur nom leur
prénom leurs adresses y compris notre
région d'ailleurs je pense aux policiers
qui sont à calais et qui ont encore
aujourd'hui moment où nous parlons sur
un site internet désormais logé à
l'étranger la liste de leurs photos avec
leurs mots leurs prénoms leur adresse
c'est rarement pour leur apporter des
chocolats à noël et j'imagine surtout
lorsqu'on voit les commentaires qui
entoure ces sites internet donc je me
suis posé la même question que vous je
n'en tire pas la conclusion que la
justice ne fait pas son travail j'en
conclus le tri-nations pénale est mal
rédigée par le gouvernement et le
législateur le deuxième point je
voudrais évoquer c'était l'idée
évidemment nul
moment dans l'esprit du gouvernement que
d'interdire aux journalistes la
possibilité de filmer de diffuser des
images
ce n'est pas du tout l'objet d'ailleurs
personne ne viendrait à penser qu'il
existe des journalistes qu'ils aient ou
qu'il n'est pas la carte de presse parce
que monsieur le rapporteur
l'une des questions est comme celle ci
vous avez vous-même dit carte de presse
mais je crois que tu es syndicats de
journalistes où certains syndicats
travailliste évoquerait avec vous le
fait que n'est pas journal celui qui a
une carte de presse mais j'en avais
celui qui se dit journaliste donc
évidemment c'est un sujet de
qualification je me permets de vous
reprendre très légèrement mais je passe
là dessus puisque personne ne vient à
penser que le journaliste dans ce qu'il
filme et diffuse les images ce n'est pas
pour attenter à la vie physique ou à la
vie psychique des policiers ou des
gendarmes puisque même journaliste on
est quand même soumis comme tout citoyen
comme les policiers les gendarmes
d'ailleurs à au code pénal et à la
protection des individus canon alors non
mise en danger
donc ce n'est ni pour empêcher les gens
et des serveurs travail ni pour faire de
la loi bavarde où il y aurait des
accusations pénales qui existeraient qui
permettrait la condamnation
ceci étant dit et sans revenir sur le
fond le sénat a décidé a évidemment
souverainement la cmp et l'assemblée
également puisque les buts
jean merci de senna dit réfléchir à ce
poisson noble
peut-être que les moyens mérite
évidemment d'être bien sûr amélioré j'ai
entendu deux choses qui kim qui m'étonne
beaucoup dans vos interventions
d'abord vous avez dit c'était le code de
la presse cet affreux pardon de vous le
dire je sais que l'assemblée que ce sont
nos positions sa majorité est désormais
convaincu des arguments du rapporteur
vous allez donc inscrire dans le code
pénal directement des dispositions qui
étaient prévues dans le code de la
presse mais c'est pas parce que quelque
chose s'appelle code de la presse que
c'est moins protecteur au plus
protecteurs le code pénal
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
amènera à créer une incrimination pénale
qui permettra la comparution immédiate
et la garde à vue
ce que ne faisait pas le code de la
presse et la disposition présentée par
le gouvernement
on a longtemps dit que le gouvernement
écrivait le texte avec ses pieds très
bien je constate cependant que le code
pénal mais il me sera porteur le sait on
a eu cet échange avant la commission et
je comprends c'est cette volonté
d'ailleurs je soutiens finalement la
plus grande
fort sa plus grande autorité que l'on
souhaite mettre pour cette incrimination
permettra sur ces faits là des
comparutions immédiates des gardes à vue
qui ne sont pas prévues lorsque c'est
dans le code de la presse deuxièmement
on a l'impression qu'on a créé un ovni
en le mettant dans le code de la presse
quand on protège aussi mais c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
république non je vous renvoie à
l'article 39 sec 16 de la loi
alors il ya eu deux modifications une en
2009 une en 95 encore 95 mais je sais
janvier 95 de ses ministres y est donc
resté vraiment charles pasqua
bon je vous lis un article 39 sexuelle
alors pour le coup du code de la presse
le fait de révéler par quelques moyens
que ce soit l'identité des
fonctionnaires de la police nationale
des militaires de personnel civil
subiste du personnes des personnels
civils pardon du ministère de la défense
ou d'un jour des doigts un appartement
des services ou des unités désignés par
arrêté des ministres intéressés et dont
les missions exigent pour des raisons de
sécurité le respect de l'anonymat
est puni d'une amende de 15000 euros
c'est à dire que il ya déjà plus
désormais de 26 ans que le législateur
et ça n'a été modifiée par aucun
gouvernement que le législateur a prévu
que le fait de filmer de diffuser des
éléments d'identification qui concerne
les policiers les gendarmes les
militaires de l'opération j'imagine
sentinelles ou le personnel
administratif de nice à l'intérieur puis
rajoute en 95 les douanes était déjà une
incrimination prévue dans le code de la
presse donc nous n'avons pas réinventer
l'eau chaude
on a pas fait d atteinte
disproportionnée à la démocratie nous
avons été un dans le code de la presse
parce que il était prévu déjà des
dispositions puisque c'est le
législateur qu'il a voulu le mettre dans
le code de la presse la loi 1881 qui a
été modifié ce présent sur des dizaines
de fois alors bien sûr c'est une grande
joie la république maintenant 90 180 à
ma connaissance il avait pas encore
internet est pas encore les réseaux
sociaux sans doute les déchets sont
d'époque étaient des gros visionnaire
mais était un peu limité quand même par
l'atmosphère
de modernité qui étaient autour de
normal d'ailleurs de l'améliorer de la
modifier la compléter comme toutefois
évidemment même si on est d'accord
ensemble que c'est une grande loi qui
fondent l'exercice républicain
démocratique notre pays mais des 95 puis
en 2009 sans jamais que ce soit supprimé
ou modifié et pourtant il ya eu beaucoup
de lois qui touchent à la sécurité ou la
liberté d'expression ces dispositions
étaient premièrement dans le code de la
presse et prévoyait déjà la pénalisation
de la diffusion de l'identité des
fonctionnaires de police et de
gendarmerie
ce que nous avons modifié ses pronos en
compte les réseaux sociaux qui est quand
même
avouons le à la fois un bien et un mal
tout dépend de comment on utilise que
deuxièmement les policiers les gendarmes
sont souvent menacé personnellement et
le drame de magnanville montre que par
ailleurs ils sont menacés dans leurs
familles et ils sont menacés parmi les
père noël personnel administratif
là la femme du policier qui a été égorgé
devant son fils à magnanville était du
personnel administratif du ministère de
l'intérieur et je ne vais pas vous faire
la revue de détail des menaces sur les
enfants ce les conjoints quand ils vont
au supermarché quand ils vont au club de
sport des policiers des gendarmes que
l'on reconnaît mais vous le savez tous
ils sont très nombreux
une fois que je vous ai dit ça je
voudrais vraiment parce que c'est un
point important éclairer le sénat sur le
fait que ces dispositions écrite dans la
loi de sécurité intérieure n'était pas
disproportionnée n'était pas contraire à
la loi 10 181 n'empêchait pas les
journées de travail et avait une base
qui était déjà celle du législateur ya
25 ans mais que nous comprenons qu'il
faut mieux rédiger le texte et que nous
faisons confiance évidemment au sénat
l'assemblée pour le faire tant que les
buts que nous cherchons à protéger c'est
à dire les opéras ces policiers
militaires en opération de police il est
bien précis en opération de police à ce
titre monsieur le rapporteur permettez
moi de vous dire également qu'il est
très différent l'article 18 on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
lors du texte séparatisme je crois que
effectivement il ne faudrait pas voter
ces amendements de suppression bien
eh bien oui madame oui explications de
vote
merci monsieur le président je ne vous
surprendrai pas en indiquant que mon
groupe va voter les amendements de
suppression de cet article mais je
voudrais puisque le rapporteur a rappelé
que le premier ministre avait annoncé le
24 novembre dernier son intention de
saisir le conseil constitutionnel
concernant cet article indiqué la chose
suivante qui pourra utilement éclairer
les travaux du conseil constitutionnel
il ya un principe qui doit toujours
s'appliquer en droit pénal quel principe
de la légalité des délits et des peines
c'est à dire que pour paraphraser on ne
peut pas être sanctionné sans que la loi
pénale soit précisé claire or il se
trouve que le parlement va voter dans
quelques instants
des dispositions qui seront également
concernés par l'article 18 du texte
principes de la république
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le signaler
ce matin je pense que c'est un problème
qui n'est pas pris à sa juste valeur
ni par le gouvernement ni par le
parlement parce que nous allons nous
trouver et vous avez aisément sous les
yeux cet article 18 des modalités qui
sont dans le code pénal
et qui c'est intéressant que le ministre
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure auront la
particularité de permettre effectivement
le recours à la comparution immédiate en
dérogation s'est dit expressément aux
règles de la loi du 29 juillet 1881 donc
nous nous avons un chevauchement total
mais qui n'est pas totalement
satisfaisant car bien évidemment il est
distinct sur certains points donc nous
nous apprêtons nous parlement à voter
des dispositions qui ne seront pas les
mêmes
à quelques semaines d'intervalle sur une
situation qui peut être analogue et
c'est pour cela que je vous alerte et je
sais que chacun veut continuer son
chemin chacun considère que le projet de
loi d'être défendu et on verra plus tard
mais c'est notre responsabilité donc
c'est pour cela qu'il faut choisir où
nous votons l'article d'aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de dire que nous souhaitions
voter ou non ou nous votons l'article 18
dans quelques semaines et l'article 20
qui prévoit l exception sur la
comparution immédiate mais faire les
deux
encore à la censure du conseil
constitutionnel merci
je
oui oui je vais mettre aux voix ces
trois amendements de suppression avec
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
donkey et pour les amendements de
suppression
qui est contre ils sont rejeté deux
amendements de rédaction global le 230
la dame l'a pris part dont adam du
kerman oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
il s'agit effectivement d'un amendement
de réécriture d'ailleurs de réécriture
qui a été travaillé avec le syndicat
national des journalistes puisque
monsieur le rapporteur
je vous ai entendu et donc vous
répéterez certainement pas les mêmes
propos parce que vous venez déjà en
anticipant dit d'y répondre
cependant et même si nous soulignons la
réécriture qui a été fait ici par la
commission des lois il nous semble qu'il
demeure quand même quelques vins
certitudes notamment sur la première
partie de cet article puisque finalement
on renvoie à la justice la
responsabilité de mise en oeuvre de ce
dispositif
je ne me revient pas non plus n'a été
dit sur la possibilité qu'il eût mieux
valu mettre en miroir avec finalement
l'article 18 de la loi séparatisme dont
discuteront dans quinze jours et donc il
semble que la nécessaire intelligibilité
de la loire mérité en tout cas de
clarifier notre débat entre ces deux
textes et puis enfin rappelé également
bien évidemment que aujourd'hui et
peut-être de plus en plus
alors certains usurpé le titre de
journaliste mais il ya quand même des
journalistes de vraies personnes qui
travaillent avec ces méthodes là et qui
sont des journalistes qui ne possèdent
pas de carte de presse et qui donc ne se
retrouve pas dans le dispositif tel que
rédigé par la commission des lois jean
merci merci monsieur grand le
l'amendement 8
merci monsieur le président bon j'ai
largement
je suis largement interview stoner mais
si je dépose et ça je le dis à la
majorité sénatoriale si j'ai déposé cet
amendement qui n'est nullement
attentatoires à la démocratie et à la
liberté de la presse c'est parce que
j'ai considéré que l'article 23 qui
prévoit d'interdire la diffusion dans le
seul cas d'intention malveillante semble
d'une application très difficile car
soumise à une appréciation subjective et
interprétative
donc je préfère quelque chose de plus de
plus carré moi je suis quand même très
étonné mes chers collègues de tout ce
que j'ai entendu depuis 48 heures parce
que le dogmatisme est vraiment au rendez
vous de ces débats police municipale
armement police
les drones les moyens modernes de tous
les moyens modernes
tout ça c'est rejeter est là aujourd'hui
mais on n'a pas nous à être sur la
défensive
on nous accuse de quoi on nous accuse si
j'ai bien compris on nous accuse de
d'être atteintes aux libertés à la
démocratie aux droits de l'homme
mais attendez je vous demande un peu de
mémoire
j'observe quand même que dans les
formations dans les sensibilités
politiques qui se sont exprimés
qu'exprime un quai c'est de nous accuser
de tous ces mots terribles
il ya quand même celles et ceux qui
historiquement ont été toujours des
défenseurs de dpi et des nations qui
elles sont les plus attentatoires à la
démocratie et aux libertés
donc il faut revenir un peu sur terre et
moi ce qui me gêne c'est d'être obligé
de me défendre dessus c'est ça qui nous
gêne voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui dire que
nous ne souhaitons pas casser fbfc news
le soir à 20h on puisse voir le visage
d'un policier qui demain sera agressée
lui sa famille ses enfants
je pense pas que ce soit quelque chose
qui puisse vous choquer dans tous les
cas je suis certain que 90 % des
français sont d'accord avec moi
bien avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur sur ces deux amendements une
précis deux précisions par rapport à ce
qu'a dit madame la présidente à ça si
d'une part ce n'est pas vous qui est
toxique
pardon excusez moi madame coeur masque
usé mais c'est quand même une voix
synchro d'une part sur l'article 18
bien sûr ça nous a pas échappé sauf que
les personnes concernées ne sont pas les
mêmes le ministre l'a dit policiens en
opération c'est là dans l'arctique 18
sont tous les citoyens d'autre part les
incriminations de sont pas les mêmes et
en troisième lieu
vous verrez qu'au moment où le débat
arrivera ici nous proposerons un article
qui assoit la complémentarité complète
entre les deux certainement
alors par contre c'est pas si je me suis
mal exprimé mais je redis que l'arctique
tel qu'il est écrit qu'est pesé au
trébuchet n'interdit évidemment pas de
filmer pour un journaliste il n'interdit
pas de diffuser mais ça vaut pour les
journalistes comme des personnes qui
n'ont pas la carte de presse on sait
lamelle mais le même régime ils peuvent
filmer et diffuser la question c'est
quand ils le font avec une
identification avec une intention
dolosive comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
alors monsieur grand suis désolé mais je
l' ai déjà dit endémies en commission le
nous ne pouvons pas dans le droit
français flouter les images des
policiers seuls les mineurs peuvent être
floutés où les catégories très
spécifiques par exemple des policiers en
opération du raid ou des mais c'est très
c'est très réglementé dans une liste
très clair depuis des années et donc moi
je ne peux pas prendre un amendement qui
s'opposent à ce qui est permis dans le
droit français donc je suis évidemment
défavorable aux deux amendements ça très
bien à vis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
défavorable
sur ces deux amendements qui sont de
réaction globale mais qui sont
différentes donc ils seront soumis au
vote séparément je vais aux voies
d'abord le 230 de la présidente à celle
ci il est le grand est retirée très bien
donc le 230 lui n'est pas retirée je le
mets aux voix avec deux avis négatifs
qui est pour
tpour bon pied contre il est rejetée le
8 et aux tirs et il n'est pas soumis au
vote rejet maintenant six amendements
discussion commune le 229 madame du
kerman oui je vais pas me répéter cet
amendement finalement vise à supprimer
les trois premier alinéa de cet article
tel que rédigé par ce qu'il nous semble
encore flou tout en en conservant la
deuxième partie tout en conservant
pardon à la deuxième partie de cet
article
mais bon je croit déjà savoir les
arguments qui vont nous y être opposés
donc nous le maintenons et nous
entendrons les arguments voir merci
c'est le 311 monsieur grand monsieur le
président monsieur très rapidement cet
amendement vise à étendre aux douaniers
le dispositif prévu dans cette
proposition de loi pour sanctionner la
diffusion d'imagés visage des policiers
et militaires aidés en raison d'un bris
nationale sur les réseaux sociaux à des
fins malveillantes c'est un complément
naturellement de l'amendement de la
commission
donc je voudrais qu'on rajoute les
douaniers parce que ça me paraît bien
sûr naturel
visiblement c'est un oubli merci le dit
ce n'est pas défendu le 175 monsieur
roux oui merci monsieur le président
donc on voudrais rajouter pour faire
suite à mon collègue aussi la liste des
agents nous paraît incomplète et
pourrait se voir ajouter les gardes
champêtres les sapeurs pompiers qui
doivent au même titre que les autres
être protégé c est monsieur roux il ya
vous avez le sens 76
oui c'est uniquement
rajouter il faudrait qu'on rajoute donc
dans sa rédaction actuelle le texte
prévoit dispose que le même peine sera
applicable en cas de provocation
identifier le conjoint le partenaire lié
par un pacte de 6,8 de solidarité de
concubins ou l'avant de la jarre
toutefois cette liste nous paraît
incomplète puisqu'elle oui notamment les
parents ascendant des agents merci le
204 monsieur raid blade amendements
rédactionnels rédactionnelles monsieur
le rapporteur sur ces cinq amendements
donc puisque celui de monsieur nation
n'est pas défendu elle vient du
défavorable sur le premier celui de 2,2
monsieur grand nous avons eu nous avons
eu le débat et nous avons convenu qu'il
fallait un article très précis ciblée
sur les forces de l'ordre en opération
donc ces policiers gendarmes policiers
municipaux
mais si on rajoute les douaniers
beaucoup de respect pour les douaniers
après un autre amendement dire on ajoute
les sapeurs-pompiers et les les gardes
champêtres
non ils seront ils ont un article de
l'article 18 de la loi valeurs de la
république qui qui s'appliquera à eux
mais nous il faut qu'on reste cibler sur
les policières ne place ils font pas
d'opérations de police menées les alizés
donc défavorable sur le le deuxième
premier amendement monsieur rousset non
sur le second par contre favorable
vous vous proposez pour mieux protéger
les familles qu'on protège aussi les
ascendants vous avez raison et monsieur
mateu blé a eu raison
avec son oeil s'agace de faire un
amendement de précision que auquel je
donne un avis favorable
très bien merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre
identique à la commission parfait alors
je prends un parent puisqu'ils sont tous
différents et le 229 avec deux avis
défavorables le 229 est 229 qui est pour
et contre
il est rejeté le 3 s'en est retirée vous
pouvez je vous en prie monsieur grand
monsieur monsieur le rapporteur
je me permets d'insister pour les
douaniers ne se sont pas les spectateurs
ce sont des ce sont des acteurs des
acteurs ils sont soumis à la délinquance
internationale ce sont des gens dont le
visage est quasiment fichiers par les
grands délinquants
ce sont des gens qui sont en première
ligne en nos frontières je vous promets
que entre avons peslier a sorti
montpellier ils sont en danger tous les
jours ils sont armés jusqu'aux dents
parce qu'enfin s'ils sont également
armés jusqu'aux dents et donc moi je
considère que la ushl a franchement ne
pas donner satisfaction d'inscrire les
douaniers comme les policiers lesquels
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses ils font
des actions communes parfois et souvent
même et qui sont confrontés à un des
länder les plus armés qui existent les
plus armés qui existent et qui ensuite
leurs portables passent les
photographies à la douane passe passe
les images partout de manière à ce
qu'ils prennent d'autres les tangentes
excusez moi là je suis quand même très
très étonnée qu'on me donne pas
satisfaction sur cet amendement
je vous demande monsieur le rapporteur
de reconsidérer votre position je vous
en remercie par avance à vie bougez pas
écoutez moi je me suis tourné vers le
ministre lui demandons qu'ils sont les
policiers en opération la réponse est
claire les policiers nationaux
les gendarmes les policiers municipaux
donc je ne peux pas dire oui monsieur le
ministre je me retrouve le présent la
commission peut pas rajouter douaniers
des opérations de police ça n'aurait pas
de sens monsieur grand mais si la
commission des lois le veut et écrit
opération de police et opérations
douanières vous y rajoutez les douaniers
mais mais
voilà c'est faut qu'on soit cohérent
donc jean galdin présent la commission
des lois est gelé ses responsabilités au
sénat de le faire s'ils le souhaitent
monsieur laporte alors j'ai bien compris
l'intention de monsieur vendons ce qu'on
peut faire c'est sous-amendé
l'amendement maîtres lors d'opérations
douanières pour que ce soit en opération
d'accord lors les douaniers virgules
lorsqu'ils sont en opération virgules et
là on peut leur ajouté attendez là là on
n'a pas de réaction claire l'avouer pas
faire peut pas faire un sous-amendement
comme ça entre deux machin donnez nous
un texte définitif est clair
attendez à leurs explications de vote
tout à son mari bien de la gontrie et
comme ça on réécrit d'un agent des
douanes alors monsieur grand et très
cohérent il faut dans ce cas soit vous
faites référence on a eu ce débat avant
le déjeuner aux personnes dépositaires
de l'autorité publique et dans ce cas là
on a une catégorie identifiée et au fond
c'est ce que souligne monsieur grands
comment faire le départ à l'intérieur
d'une catégorie pour considérer ce à
l'égard de qu'elle se serait plus grave
ce serait moins grave etc
on est dans une espèce de deux
catalogues donc ce qu'il propose je ne
suis pas d'accord parce que je ne suis
pas d'accord avec l'article mais
l'amendement suivant qui parle des
gardes champêtres
c'est la même chose et puis on va parler
des élus d'ailleurs l'article 20 du
texte principes de la république fait
référence aux personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique
donc c'est bien la con et on voit qu'on
nage en pleine confusion et que cet
article ne fonctionne pas donc si vous
êtes cohérent nous ne voterons pas mais
vous devriez voté l'amendement de luxe
grand
monsieur richard j'ai pris d'une part
quand nous sommes dans ce genre de
débats qui parlent de droit pénal
je me permets de rappeler aux collègues
que dans le droit pénal et les autres
textes de nature pénale
il ya environ dix mille infractions qui
sont définies par la loi
la réalité d'ailleurs de cette profusion
c'est que les procureurs vous explique
qui en a au maximum 150 ou 200 qui sont
effectivement utilisées poursuivi ils
ont chacune de ces infractions doit
avoir une définition stricte et précise
donc il est tout à fait compréhensible
est logique qu'il y ait des infractions
de définition assez voisines et je peux
faire observer à ma collègue de la
gontrie
il est extrêmement fréquent qu'une
poursuite soit s'engager
poursuite soit engagé pour plusieurs
motifs différents en plusieurs
infractions différentes
tout le monde sait ça donc nous allons
adopter une disposition qui porte sur
des policiers ou des gendarmes dans une
situation exposée dans une situation de
danger
je pense que jean pierre grand a raison
et que dans certaines circonstances dans
certains types de services des douaniers
peuvent être aussi exposés à des dangers
c'est comme ça qu'il faut compléter nous
devons et le rapporteur est en train de
le faire a ajouté cette circonstance il
est clair que au moment du travail en
cmp il faudra caractériser les
conditions de services de douanes qui
comporte ce danger de manière à ne pas
si j'ose dire a osé trop large
bien alors non attendez une seconde
monsieur grands est-ce que vous acceptez
d'abord de sous-amendé enfin un
sous-amendement qui serait d'un agent
des douanes
lorsqu'il est en opération rien dire
monsieur le président oui tout à fait ça
me parait ça me paraît logique et ses
eaux
voilà je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
au collègue richard et vie et je suis
accord est le bon sens bon avis de la
commission alors si c'est un amendement
sous-amendé un abandon a rectifié par
monsieur grand donc d'un agent des
douanes lorsqu'il est en opération
vous êtes favorable à vis du
gouvernement favorable
alors je remettrai jamais aux voix donc
l'amendement de monsieur grand rectifié
comme on vient de le dire d'un agent des
douanes lorsqu'il est en opération cette
fois ci avec deux avis favorables qui
est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté sur le 175 rectifier cette
fois ci avec deux âmes deux avis
défavorables qui est pour et qui est
contre
il est rejeté le 176 cette fois ci avec
deux avis favorable qu'est pour qui est
contre il est adopté le 204 que
rédactionnel avec deux avis favorables
qui est pour et qui est contre
il est adopté un scrutin public
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public
oui mais attendez vous ferez
l'explication de vote sur l'article oui
je vous la donne dès que j'ai dit merci
donc j'ai été saisi d'une demande au
scrutin public par le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains sur
l'ensemble de de l'article 24 avant de
procéder au vote qui souhaitent
s'exprimer en sus du rhin le président
excusez-moi de vous savoir un peu pressé
nous voterons contre cet article c'est
évident pour quantité de raisons la
première c'est que cet article par sa
forme est porteur de tous les défauts du
texte deux versions une procédure
accélérée une ppl qui veut se faire
aussi grosse qu'un pjl une commission
exotique à l'assemblée nationale qui
n'attend même pas la navette
parlementaire pour nous laisser le temps
de travailler la confusion voire la
redondance avec le article 18 sur un
texte qui arrive en même temps devant le
parlement
il était inutile et dangereux cet
article 24 au terme de notre rapporteur
et de quelques autres écrits avec les
pieds alors heureusement la commission a
repris la main mais est-ce que c'est
suffisant à notre avis non parce qu'il
est toujours inutiles et qu'ils restent
imprécis ce délit de provocation à
l'identification ne nous paraît pas
satisfaisant il paraît de plus peu
applicable on nous a dit regardez
magnanville et on voit bien que
l'effectivité opérationnel de cet
article malheureusement n'aurait pas
empêché un certain nombre de drames donc
aller prétexté qu'on peut empêcher des
drames
alors que ce n'est pas le cas et
dangereux s'agissant de la presse on est
sorti de la loi de 1881 cet heureux
parce qu'il reste ce droit d'informer ce
droit d'être informé et que il ya quand
même un climat autour de ce texte qui
empêche les journalistes de travailler
dans de bonnes conditions
200 journalistes ont été empêchés de
travailler par les forces de l'ordre ces
deux dernières années il y a des gardes
à vue
il y à une autocensure ce climat nous
paraît dangereux
deuxième point qui nous paraît
déterminant
cet article 24 est le symptôme d'un
échec
c'est un constat d'échec sur l'état des
rapports entre la police et la
population
un gendarme me disait l'autre jour quand
on en est là c'est qu'on a échoué dans
notre mission de prévention et dans dans
notre insertion avec la population c'est
un échec dans la conduite des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre auquel cet
article 24 est particulièrement attaché
c'est la nasse c'est nous seuls nous ne
sommes pas dans le même camp madame
c'est une doctrine d'emploi qui cherche
l'escaladé
ils n'ont pas la désescalade alors sans
effets de tribune sans emphase
nous aurions aimé un texte plus haut
de mieux construire juridiquement une
réflexion plus aboutie sur la question
des images et puis pour paraphraser un
défenseur des libertés publiques il
disait avec ce texte les drones
l'article 24 à l'article 21 articles 25
on ne sait pas ce qu'on gagne en termes
de sécurité on voit très clairement en
revanche tout ce qu'on perd en termes de
liberté 1
la parole est au président retailleau
bien sûr que nous allons voter cet
article qui était profondément remanié
par la commission et je voudrais saluer
le rapporteur marc philippe daubresse et
le président de la commission des lois
et je voudrais parce que je n'y résiste
pas m'adresser au ministre l'intérieur
monsieur vie intérieure si le sénat
n'existe pas il faudrait l'inventer
cet article était mal née mais
l'objectif était nécessaire il
s'agissait et c'est tout le sens de la
nouvelle injection de protéger dans des
circonstances difficiles dans un moment
où l'ultra violence se déchaîne contre
les forces de l'ordre
il s'agissait de protéger les gendarmes
les policiers de tout ce qui peut
constituer un ciblage via les réseaux
sociaux et qui peut mettre en danger
dans un lynchage numérique mais qui se
terminent parfois aussi malheureusement
par des lynchages physique
ces forces de l'ordre qui sont bouclier
d'après la république et nous parvenons
justement a trouvé bon point d'équilibré
je crois parce que ce qui était reproché
c'est cette confusion entre l'objectif
bien compris de la protection des forces
de l'ordre mais où en même temps on
avait eu le sentiment que la liberté
d'information pourrait être que la
liberté de diffusion de captation même
lors de ces manifestations pouvait être
entravée je crois que la commission des
lois et j'espère que le sénat votera cet
article nouvellement rédigé parce que on
parvient précisément à articuler la
protection des forces de l'ordre
évidemment sans toucher à la loi sur la
liberté de la presse qui est fondatrice
de notre république de 1881 et je pense
que c'est important c'est la raison pour
laquelle
je pense que là le sénat en réalité fait
une oeuvre utile pour les forces de
l'ordre et je pense bien monsieur le
ministre que vous allez le souligner
merci monsieur le président la pole est
un monsieur marc laménie qu'est ce qu'il
peut dire bah oui merci monsieur le
président sur mini ce cher collègue très
très rapidement pour simplement
modestement parler après le président
mais giresse et plus et une modeste
intervention vous irez peut-être plus à
titre personnel pour rappeler bon dans
un premier temps la liberté de la presse
qui est fondamental je pense que là tous
sont convaincus mais de l'autre côté
j'irai même si dans certains corps dont
certains amendements apparaît c'est le
terme violences policières
malheureusement il ya pu avoir aussi des
des situations isolées qu'on peut aussi
malheureusement regretter mais je crois
qu'il faut toujours quand même avoir
présent à l'esprit que l'ensemble des
forces de ces de sécurité risquent leur
vie au quotidien pour sauver aussi des
débits sécurité des personnes et des
biens
et chaque année malheureusement que ce
soit les les sapeurs pompiers les
policiers les gendarmes les militaires
il ya malheureusement une vingtaine de
décès en service chaque année donc je
pense que ça malheureusement on en parle
trop peu
malheureusement et je pense qu'il faut
aussi l'avoir présent à l'esprit
et puis je partage aussi notre collègue
rond sonoma l'amendement graisseuse
amende le sous-amendement qui ont été
adoptées parce que élu d'un département
frontalier
[Musique]
l'administration des douanes qui certes
dépendent du ministère de l'économie et
des finances joue aussi un rôle
complémentaire par rapport aux à
l'ensemble des des forces de sécurité et
notamment aussi il ya aussi des démos
tort ils sont aussi sûrs et ils peuvent
aussi intervenir sur des missions que la
fouille des véhicules par exemple que ne
peuvent pas forcément le fait faire les
effectuer les policiers les gendarmes
donc il ya une réelle complémentarité
sur lequel aussi toutes et tous méritent
aussi l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
mérite respect et reconnaissance donc je
soutiendrai cet article
bon l'encouragé pas allez monsieur lui
dit si vous le permettez
il ya encore deux orateurs je
préfèrerais que vous preniez la parole à
l'issue
madame gatel merci monsieur le président
comme beaucoup de nous tous sans doute
je rêverais d'amande qui serait marquée
par la sagesse la bienveillance et la
fraternité des hommes
or ce monde n'existe pas même si nous
efforçons les uns et les autres de le
construire
moi je souhaiterais rappeler d'où vient
cet article et je crois qu'il faut que
nous osions nommer les choses et parler
de la violence et du détournement qui
est fait régulièrement dans des
manifestations de la liberté et de
l'instrumentalisation qui est fait pour
d'autres objectifs que celui d'une
expression de point de vue et je ne peux
m'empêcher comme nous tous ici de penser
aux hommes et aux femmes qui ont été
victimes de l' usage d'image totalement
détournées à des fins extrêmement
malveillantes
cet article effectivement à petit eu
quelques erreurs de conception quelques
erreurs de naissance mais en tout cas
moi je salue le travail qui a été fait
par les rapporteurs mcrib daubresse et
loïc hervé pour essayer de trouver une
solution qui soit extrêmement
respectueuse de la liberté de la presse
et le sénat est le garant des libertés
et je crois que vous avez su trouver cet
équilibre de sécurité et de protection
et de liberté de la presse et je vous
félicite de votre créativité juridique
extrêmement argumenté et monsieur le
ministre je sais pas ce que vous ne
l'avez dit en commission que vous
accompagnerez avec bienveillance et avec
sagesse c'est ainsi que vous n'avez dit
cette proposition donc le groupe
centriste votre à cet article en
exprimant à nouveau sa gratitude aux
rapporteurs
merci la parole de questeur sueur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le président retailleau j'ai
été très étonné par l'espèce de
mièvrerie avec laquelle ça n'est pas
habituel chez vous vous vantiez le point
d'équilibré qui serait atteint
vraiment cela m'a étonné j'ai vu que
madame gatel en avait rajouté une louche
dans le même thème nous savons donc 1.1
point des livres alors c'est quoi le
point d'équilibré
nous nous avons une position très claire
un respect intégral est totale de la
liberté de la presse
2 il ya déjà dix articles dans la loi
qui sont là pour protéger les policiers
les gendarmes contre toute forme
d'agression
ces deux points sont claires le point
d'équilibré
c'est quoi c'est la provocation dans le
but de l'identification dans le but
c'est à dire que ce dont il est question
ce sont les intentions
bon courage monsieur le président
retailleau a qui va définir l'intention
voyons quelles sont vos intentions par
exemple c'est d'une question qu'on
pourrait se poser une vraie question
parce que lorsqu'il y a il y aura une
photo de policiers une photo de
manifestations dans un journal neutre si
ça existe on dira il n'y a pas
d'intention ses objectifs mais quand un
journal militant un journal d'opinion
publiera une photo on dira ce journal il
n'est pas gouvernementale il n'est pas
pour l'ordre établi il défend des idées
bah oui des immeubles sur otayo alors
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là une intention
une intention de provocation et donc
c'est parfaitement gélatineuse ça c'est
dit pas grand chose c'est inapplicable
mes chers collègues et on se fait
plaisir en disant qu'il y à un point
d'équilibré
il n'y a aucun poil équilibre il ya une
démission du parlement
une des missions du sénat ce sont les
juges et la jurisprudence qui parleront
des intentions
bien
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre la situation
monsieur le président d'après le
président retailleau m'inviter à
renverser le sénat je le fais bien
volontiers
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour mes
illustres prédécesseurs et
singulièrement pour les manceaux qui
passa beaucoup de temps à vouloir
exclure le sénat d'institutions pour
finalement finir et qui était vendu 1
mais je ne suis pas certain que vous y
mettiez la même personnalité politique
pour vous ce président bataille aux
dents j'entends bien jamais je ne vais
arrêter je me permettais pas vraiment ça
appartient à tout le monde sans doute
mais en même temps on les on les a déjà
mais en même temps maire de la parole
merci monsieur le président mais en même
temps je le fais bien volontiers
monsieur le président retailleau et moi
je suis personnellement très attachée au
bicamérisme et j'ai pas voulu tout à le
reprendre parce que celui là nous avons
eu des échanges aigres-doux ce matin
évoquant disait n'importe quoi quand
vous avez procédure simplifiée dans
votre déclaration thaler vous aviez vous
même fait si je peux me permettre une
inexactitude puisque au contraire le
fait mais que ces échanges entre deux
assemblées existe et que le gouvernement
par nature n'est pas seul la rédaction
monopole de la rédaction des lois et que
la cmp décide sans le gouvernement par
ailleurs et j'ai une bonne chose pour
les textes de la république donc je le
fais bien volontiers
le deuxième point je voudrais évoquer
c'est que nous avons manifestement à des
accords mais ça désaccord d'opinion et
c'est bien légitime en démocratie sur
cet article 27 ou en tout cas ses buts
j'ai trop entendu violences policières
pour répondre parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que pour moi c'est
cet oxymore n'existait pas on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
et j'ai par contre un énervement
quotidien lorsque j'entends divorce
entre la police et la population
mesdames et messieurs les élus et je
m'inclus dans cette province
si nous avions les taux d'affection de
la population qu'à la police nationale
gendarmerie je crois que nous serions
tous des élus comblé je crois que le
divorce est plus grand entre les
institutions notamment mais bien sûr
c'est vrai le modèle démocratique
gouvernementale et la population contre
la police et la population
les policiers les gendarmes sont les
enfants du peuple c'est les soldats de
l'an ii
ce sont les enfants des classes
populaires et moyennes de france qui
s'engage c'est rarement les patrons du
cac40 j'ai l'occasion de dire qu envoie
des gardiens de la paix aux écoles de
police
c'est rarement c'est rarement le cas
c'est les enfants du peuple et ils sont
partis de la population que la police
soit la police de l'état est la police
de la nation et pas l'appeler du
gouvernement c'est effectivement quelque
chose auquel il faut que nous fassions
tous collectivement attention c'est une
certitude mais personne ne peut nier que
si la violence
elle est avant tout contre les forces de
l'ordre dans toutes les manifestations
des gilet jaune je lis bien volontiers
que je n'étais pas mis à l'intérieur à
l'époque il n'y a pas eu alors qu'elle
était extrêmement violente extrêmement
spontanée sans aucun sens aucun des
compagnons de service d'ordre
on va pas refaire le débat d'hier mais
enfin c'est comme une vérité dans des
villes de province qui n'avait jamais
connu tous les samedis pendant un an les
violences que nous avons vues contre les
biens contre les personnes et je ne me
mets pas en cause la colère qui a pu
faire naître chez nos concitoyens ce
sujet c'est un autre débat en face et
manifestation existe et elle est
extrêmement violente
on a demandé des policiers dont ce
n'était pas le métier c'était pas le
métier de faire du match à de l'ordre et
peut-être que c'était un problème enfin
c'est ce qui s'est passé c'est ce qui
s'est passé et qu'est ce qui se passe il
n'y a pas eu un décès de la part des
forces de l'ordre dans ces
manifestations d'une extrême violence
pendant un an et demi par godin et
messieurs les sénateurs
il ya eu trois mille deux cents blessés
chez les policiers
chez les gendarmes tu as eu à mort
pas eu un mort chez les manifestants pas
eu un mort chez les manifestants
et quand il ya eu quand il ya eu au
moins vous savez ma lecture préférée
n'est pas n'est pas celle du journal le
monde
mais j'ai regardé cet après midi comme
mon métier me l'obligent les journaux et
j'ai vu une interview de la défenseur
des droits vous n'avez pas cité depuis
ce matin c'est dommage pourtant depuis
non l'interview de madame la leaf à son
endroit dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
c'était quand même quelque chose qui
devrait quand même vous interpellez
puisque depuis 10 heures est en ligne et
puis elle est imprimée désormais et je
le sais dans beaucoup de vos casier
madame la défenseure des droits elle
même et vos que le schéma de match alors
que le gouvernement a proposé a mis en
place est un large au progrès pour les
manifestations
donc non semana défenseur des droits qui
ai dit si tu es cité cantons sur le
canton chanta vérité on la chante pas à
moitié disait un chanteur que le parti
communiste aimé bien donc s'il vous
plaît si ton truc complètement
moi je veux dire à quel point statique
24 est important et qu'il n'y a aucune
antinomie entre l'amour de la liberté et
singulièrement la liberté de la presse
et l'amour des forces de l'ordre de la
protection des forces de l'ordre parce
que là où nous avons sans doute une
divergence d'opinion qui n'a pas
toujours été celle je le dis et je le
dis doit près du extérieur mais comme
respectueux j'espère que ça sera pas vu
comme une offense toujours pensé par
celle du parti socialiste j'ai cité
manuel valls j'ai cité bernard cazeneuve
je crois que il y avait à l'époque des
jo qui osé dire quand même qu'il n'y
avait pas d'incompatibilité entre
l'amour des forces de l'anp de leur
protection l'ordre profonde nécessaire
protection et la liberté parce que d'un
certain ordre et d'une certaine police
ni la liberté et je suis très heureux
monsieur prison retailleau en effet que
le sénat ait suivi le gouvernement dans
sa volonté de protéger les forces de
l'ordre
et c'est une excellente chose les
violences si elle existe en premier lieu
elles ont lieu contre les hommes et les
femmes de la république qui font leur
travail
bien je vous rappelle que j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains sur la tête 24 il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
nous suivons en ce moment même sur
l'antenne de public sénat et en direct
l'examen la proposition de loi de
sécurité globale et du fameux article 24
dont vous venez de suivre pendant une
heure et demie l'examen des amendements
avec une mobilisation assez forte on l'a
entendu des groupes de gauche des
socialistes des écologistes ou encore
des communistes qui ont déposé par
exemple des amendements de suppression
de l'article
alors ces amendements de suppression
n'ont pas été adoptés on a vu ensuite
l'examen de différents amendements pour
retoucher cet article 24 mai les
sénateurs qui ont largement déjà réécrit
le texte de l'assemblée nationale on le
sait les députés voulaient sanctionner
la diffusion malveillantes d'image des
forces de l'ordre les sénateurs ont
réécrit en commission le texte
il s'agit maintenant de créer un délit
de provocation à l'identification de ces
forces de l'ordre lorsqu'elles sont en
opération et c'est donc cette version du
texte sur laquelle ils vont voter tout
de suite les sénateurs c'est un scrutin
public ça signifie que al'inverse des
amendements qu'on a pu déjà examiné
depuis 14h30 à main levée eh bien on va
voter avec des cartes de vote ce qui
signifie qu'avec la délégation bâton va
pouvoir savoir ce que chacun dans
l'hémicycle chaque sénateurs à voter sur
le texte
donc les présidents de groupes pourront
rassembler comme ça et bien les opinions
les votes de tous les sénateurs de leur
groupe ils vont pouvoir de façon
numérique
l'entrée dans la machine de vote qui est
se trouve dans l'hémicycle et on va
pouvoir avoir sur l'écran qui est
disposée sur les côtés de l'hémicycle le
détail un groupe politique mais le
détail par chaque sénateur aussi avec
son siège du vote sur l'article 24 dans
sa nouvelle écriture avec les aime les
amendements par exemple on a vu cet
amendement de jean pierre grand qui
inclut les douaniers par exemple ce qui
n'était pas prévu dans la copie de la
commission et bien il a réussi à faire
changer d'avis
marc philippe daubresse le rapporteur et
l'air et donc les douaniers sont
maintenant inclus dans la protection de
cet article 24 et donc le scrutin est en
cours au nom où je vous parle dès que
roger karoutchi orale et voilà on va
pouvoir écouter
du coup le vote tout de suite
voici le résultat du scrutin 92 sur
l'article 24 tonnes
compte tenu de l'ensemble des
délégations de vote accordés par les
sénateurs groupes politiques et notifié
la présidence nombre de votants 345
nombre de suffrages exprimés 345 pour
l'adoption 248 contre 97
le sénat a adopté l'article 24
[Musique]